do you know this guy right here Bernard
Arno he's the richest man in the world
and the CEO and the chairman of a luxury
fashion brand of Louis Vuitton Moye
Hennessy on the outside his company is
Iconic for their flamboyant purses and
the bags coming in at thousands of
dollars each but on the inside there's
nothing flamboyant about the company or
Bernard whatsoever this makes sense
because Bernard didn't found a single
one of the dozens of fashion brands that
he owns today he actually got a start in
his family's construction business which
gave him enough money to buy out the
parent company of a Christian Dior from
there he would engage in constant
corporate raiding hostile takeovers and
brutal backstabbing to build the Empire
that is lvmh today